[Music]
what would you guys do if you discovered
you were fed by your roommates or three
roommates their foot shavings what why
would they do that like they think it's
funny I probably I was probably a
printer somehow suita asses like is it
like the day after or in might the
minute I put it in my mouth and like
guess what what's in the meatballs I
don't know
and what's the intent like they're
cooking it down just to get back to me
that find out or it's like a prayer all
day yeah those are really good
ingredients of this nobody could have
escalated like they could have been like
pranksters with you know and then it
just went to down yeah then I prank you
by beating your ass just a prank bro
yeah exactly
or do I live with three supermodels
you'd be down to you supermodels
machines better true true I don't know
but somehow when it's a supermodel it
makes everything tastier bro
where's she at like foot fungus well
that's diff what's supermodel phone
thuggish yes yeah sexy foot fungus yeah
it's like if I had to choose between a
non supermodel like as mad Borat's homie
for sometimes it makes it better right
it's weird
well I'd rather go supermodels oh look
your foot during sex
yeah but not during but if she had
fungus well they both have fungus right
so am I gonna choose whose fungus I'll
choose the supermodel fungus yeah would
you rather lick hazmats foot fungus
which is the Malolos or jealous just
Momo's foot fungus as mad as a mat in
the world Ron Jeremy's foot fungus yeah
ron jeremy adjacent my mom who's whose
foot would you taste them alone that's
what we're saying it's just we don't
know why it's just fungus it's better
yeah here's another question Jason Momoa
or a Casey chan obviously hello
I already like your fungus I'm kidding
okay so this story here happened
Maisie Wuhan Chon Chon night Chan okay
so this happened in Iowa this is the
northwest Iowa community college
students there were four roommates and
three of these girls decided it was a
great idea to feed their fourth their
fourth roommate [ __ ] so there was a
bag of shredded cheese
they added there they're dry like foot
skin
oh those was like powder into this
cheese and then fed it to their roommate
see I feel like I can know that intent
because those girls are probably
malicious type the guys I flagged
they're just find it funny email is
disgusting my flip those because girls
are usually nicer and cleaner so for
them to do something like that they
wanted to get back at her I mean girl
[ __ ] yeah they're 20 so they do 20 year
olds in the 19 year old it sounds like a
supermodel age well it's a nursing
student now they're not so they're just
nurses the other one the former are
honorless students all they're nerds
I don't busted yeah yeah they're
probably ugly as hell yeah so we
consensus is if you don't want to like -
oh they're not supermodels these are
Asian pop feet the Miss America there
are doctors and Stefan doesn't fake you
know they make that [ __ ] up some pockets
impossible possible - Dean come on the
possibly home is there
if they're that hot they're not spending
time in school if you are hit me up but
yeah so all three students they got
charged with assault oh yeah deadly
weapon because of the fungus yeah
assault assault with a deadly someone
shaken I know stuff like that is
considered like a felony damn cuz like
making people eat the girls were licking
the ice cream or even the guys and
that's a I forgot that's like a it's a
good act of terrorism almost oh [ __ ]
contaminating yeah or like coughing in
somebody same kind of [ __ ] yeah so I
what about coming on somebody's face so
how'd they find out okay
that's the thing I want to know I was
about to say I don't know how she found
out I don't know but whatever
circumstance was around the incident
like how long was she eating it before
she found out like did they never ask
the real question like was she like
going in and then she sees like I don't
know what the [ __ ] was the situation but
we need to we need a we need to hire
some people now for sure to investigate
these things and ask the hard questions
like wine like supermodels get photo
reference because that's what we're all
wondering is is how hot are the girls
because I think the crime would be
lesser depending on how hot the ladies
are what other ones if they had amazing
personalities
it doesn't matter its foot fungus or
smells about after hot it does matter
like really prove that we really where
you moved all for that personality
doesn't matter if it's foot fungus how
did they how does she find out does she
find have you been boy oh sorry I'm so
sorry you say about how they were I
would imagine they all live together so
she probably heard them like laughing
about it between the walls and it or
date door but like you know what you
just ain't [ __ ] you just eight foot
[ __ ] you shouldn't have [ __ ] slept
with my boyfriend at that [ __ ] frat
party [ __ ] and when they were to jail
they [ __ ] lied and corroborated what
we were just doing the prank because you
know we're just all roommates
I'm in some other [ __ ] of a minor oh man
that's one scary thing about being a
girl is you don't know who you could
trust man only about being a guy you
could trust everyone four guys you see
what you gay is that you were you saying
to what you all guys you can trust yeah
yeah aw damn that's relative you said
that I'm like I don't know where to go
that's true though all guys you could
trust thank you John
Trust is a people you worked with right
woman I wouldn't call them guys columns
they're political competition see that's
different
so everyone goes by professional titles
that's like nothing gender can the Bulls
trust the Lakers I don't think so
can they trust them okay so can the
Democrats trust the Republicans never
never never never never never
so I would say guys you could trust but
then you no longer become a guy if you
become a thing
so bottom line no one can trusts anyone
and the fungus on how bottles are always
delicious always have you had gone
through any mean girl [ __ ] like this cuz
I've been I've seen some [ __ ] growing up
and I was like that's some fucked-up
[ __ ] girls while I laugh I know right I
told you guys about that one time where
this was this is more like a prank it
wasn't like in like with bad intent but
it's so gross but my best friend and I
we were in her backyard it had just
rained there was this used pad so
bloodied pad by the colored trash cans
were high school yeah I think I think
high school that's pretty old yeah so
then um like I don't know why the [ __ ]
because there was so many other girls
that live there so who the [ __ ] knows
whose pad this was but this [ __ ] she
picks it up and then she goes oh my god
imagine if I
this in your face and I was like you
[ __ ] better not even there
[ __ ] no I'm gonna kill you and then
after I said whatever the [ __ ] I said
she threw it at me and landed on my face
screaming I chased her but this [ __ ] is
fast she's [ __ ] fast cuz she was a
soccer player oh you can't do that was
she's also like way more dense than me
and I was this [ __ ] twig like so what
we gonna do when you caught her kiss her
I don't know what else to do like if I
was in your shoes no I tried chasing her
down I couldn't catch up to her finally
somehow things settled but I was like
fuming I ran out of breath or something
no was this on if it still i'll get you
[ __ ] she's all [ __ ] running with the
pad like [ __ ] [ __ ] no and then i
just went inside and i scrub the [ __ ]
out my cheek cuz a little itchy why
would someone just leave a dirty [ __ ]
pad on the ground it was that and then
why the [ __ ] would you pick it up and
throw it to your best friend's dog [ __ ]
up people i like where we playing like
go blue playing football and then
they'll just see like dogs and they'll
just lure with the hands grab my friend
did that dog [ __ ] with his bare hands
anywhere black like that look that guys
are nasty like weird out of a girl I
have a question when I hit your face
this thick or did it like bounce off
your face they bounce it kind of went
like oh like the kind of a mirror yeah
heavy so as you were running out there
and you still had blood on your face a
little bit yeah oh no
it was that's a massive piece nasty and
then four years I still held like this
[ __ ] like burning grudge inside of me
girls do I never I never really acted on
it I think the worst I did once was like
her hairspray thing I think I dumped out
I poured like juice or some [ __ ] it was
something back you sure it never felt
satisfying like piano but you should
know who she has to like we should get
her back yeah I don't we don't really
talk too much perfect
what would some bird what would
something that you do back that you
would consider that's even do the same
thing same thing [ __ ] throw a
disgusting blood no actually for me on
us to be more has to be a bloody tampon
stick it up your nose or some [ __ ] with
a little pop outside Justin go to your
house or get someone like would deliver
like maybe pizza right and there's not a
part of it how many partners have done
that already
I know but then doing it in real life
yeah pizza right and then I'll be like
oh did you order pizza right and Shuba
oh and then she opens the box and my
hand will be in there with a tampon good
yes but I feel like it would only feel
satisfying to find it though
are you come on the side I have that we
have to be the one that honor you know
like I have to do it my guys didn't have
a pranky relationship we did it a little
bit shoe polishers no she never did she
just laughed and you're just like you
probably dislike that piss her off
probably I don't know it was high school
[ __ ] no I don't know sometimes you do
[ __ ] in high school could be so fun it's
so dumb we just got like I put in the
class with her boyfriend or something
was even your fault I don't think I have
no idea I've seen some girls mean girl
[ __ ] in high school they [ __ ] his girl
up because she was getting too much boy
attention
like literally they beat her ass up oh
[ __ ] that's not mean cause a new heart
that's really mean girls
[Music]